we're fortunate that right now she's
actually sleeping pretty well at
nighttime she's not a great day Napper
but she's a great night sleeper and like
that's that's a lot better because if we
can sleep you know right for the day but
um but it's been good but we have like a
few episodes left here and then I can do
like the dad thing full-time at least
until I happened in the next project so
looking forward to spending a little
more time with her well look like for
you I don't know just being around more
I guess it's like being here less hours
and and with her more I don't know so I
try to be as hands-on as I possibly can
be I mean changing diapers and feeder I
kind of give her for 7 p.m. bottle every
you know every night that I'm around at
7:00 p.m. so just more of that stuff I
guess this one your castmates ed the
Alpha Evie a good dad and that you
already kind of works your bad bad jokes
I don't know that's about I don't know
the liars who doesn't love a good dad
joke I don't know you know it just like
a stupid dad joke I don't have any up
the top of my head I don't know why
they're trying to sell me out like that
it's not like I have a repertoire of dad
jokes I go to I really don't even know
what they're talking about no not at all
I hate each other I really enjoyed it
and thanks yeah right so first episode
we come back we pick up right where we
left off of last season we are about to
go jump back to the 70s Berkeley trying
to make sure the Lucy's parents you know
are well it's kind of really confusing
but we're trying to save her sister what
we're trying to do okay we're trying to
save her sister and then something gets
massively the playing is daeviated and
Lucy gets stolen and so we sort of pick
back up immediately but then we quickly
cut to six weeks later and you see that
the time team is we've got a new
headquarters Lucy's gone you see kind of
what life has been like for these people
that are sort of now on the run and in a
way
so we picked back up from there and you
know really Wyatt in his head space he's
all about trying to get Lucy back I mean
I think it's a mission failure number
one for him and that's not who he is he
doesn't fail a mission and number two
it's Lucy and if it's not his wife his
wife is his Achilles heel and it seems
like Lucy is a I don't even know if I
want to say a number two behind his wife
she might be up there too so he is gonna
kind of do whatever he needs to do to
get her back and keep her safe and so
he's sort of pick him up he's sort of a
caged animal stuck in this like bunker
you know abandoned missile silo just
wanting to go get Lucy
yeah I'm cheering for them people seem
to be loving the lion Lucy relationship
like crazy yeah between the two names I
feel like maybe I like woo see better
but I think Ally it is like the one that
people voted on so I guess it's got to
be live but no I'm rooting for them as a
couple I mean it's kind of that classic
case of sexual tension that has
blossomed into something real and
something that has depth and and I think
they both have these feelings and for
whatever reasons you know they can't act
on them and then you know when we pick
up here in season two and they're
literally not together so yeah I don't
know I'm kind of I'm with the fans I'm
with them I'll root for him I try to I
try to pitch that romance to the writers
yeah yeah it was an interesting time for
you guys you know when you had that
moment of the cancellation and coming
back and then finding out
it was that time like for you and being
here now yeah well that was actually a
rollercoaster of three days for me
because it was a winds at first of all I
was pretty optimistic about the show
coming back I knew we had great DVR
stuff we've got such a huge fan base and
really passionate which has just
exploded
more by the way but that was a Wednesday
I think we we found out we were
cancelled and as an actor you sort of
always justified like why things
happened I mean I got we all do but you
know like it was like alright well that
that happened now I can go back to LA I
can see my friends I can you know live
my life in LA we were shooting in
Vancouver and and then Friday my wife
comes down in the morning and tells me
we're pregnant
and and I'm like that's it that's why
okay that's the sign that why we're
supposed to be here and then Saturday
morning Sean Ryan who's the exec
producer calls me and he's like hey yeah
so change of plans here NBC actually
changed their minds they're picking up
the show we're gonna be in LA and it was
just like it was mind-blowing
so that was my three days and I think
maybe later that night or something very
quickly we were on a plane going to New
York for upfront switch it up fronts it
was kind of like at least to me it felt
like the huge story because everybody
wanted to ask us about you know what
what happened because a lot of times
second season shows they don't get as
much coverage going to up front so it's
like a pilot or a first season or not a
pilot but a first season show and but we
went up there and everybody's just like
wanted no question that what happened
how'd it go what were your feelings you
know so it was it's pretty crazy but
it's almost like that became a story in
and of itself and I think from there the
fans just came out of the woodwork I
mean fandom has really blown up for this
show I mean that's the whole reason that
we're back is because the fans I mean I
really hope that fans love season 2 here
because that's that's why we're here and
that's why we're doing season 2 is for
the fans so I hope they get out of it
what what they want and if they loved
last year like obviously they did I
think they're gonna love this year - is
it feels like we're picking right back
up with the same type of stuff and
really expanding the danger and the
stakes even more so I think they're
gonna love it a lot of it is basically
kind of sleeper cells right
right yeah yeah so instead of like
instead of Flynn being the bad guy that
we had to go back and find Flynn and see
what he's doing it's it's now a sleeper
cell thing where Rittenhouse is I think
why it says it he says they're playing a
long game where they've actually planted
sleeper cells all throughout history so
we can literally go anywhere and that
could be you know you know I don't know
ulysses s grant could be Rittenhouse and
and that's our whole thing is now we're
gonna figure out where these sleeper
cells are and try to bring them down
there's a big sort of change in Flynn we
sort of see him change a little bit you
see the I should say the relationship
between the time team and Flynn changes
a lot throughout the course of the
season I think fans are gonna love
seeing that and yeah it's just kind of
like expanding that Rittenhouse danger
this season you know what I love being
in Vancouver in those summer months I
think as we all know ones like October
it's it's just wet and and I guess
colder than usual last year because it's
snowed with like good snow a few times
it's funny we were we were shooting a a
Western episode last year which I know
the bass Reeves episode last year I got
the script and I was like this is a
Western and we're it's like the middle
of rainy season in Vancouver what's how
does that line up ended up snowing like
big-time during that episode and it
looked beautiful we were at this rock
quarry and there's snow everywhere and
it looked gorgeous and it was really
really fitting but I loved being up that
in Vancouver for the summer time I loved
the weekends that I had off just to kind
of play and see the city and and I loved
driving up to Whistler and that sea to
sky highway was incredible and but you
know what I just wished that I could
have experienced it more than I even was
able to I was working so many hours that
I didn't get to enjoy it as much as I
feel like I could have like if I could
just go up there and spend like a month
doing nothing
I loved it man it would be awesome
because I loved I loved doing the hiking
stuff and all that so it's a beautiful
beautiful place